cantos de muerte al dictador mientras el
dolor se convierte en rabia en el
funeral de más ánimo para los dolientes
hay pocas dudas sobre quién mató a la
joven de 22 años acusan a la policía de
la moral de irán de haber golpeado a la
mujer hasta la muerte
una afirmación negada por las
autoridades
hasta ahora no hay pruebas de que las
autoridades le hayan pegado estamos
siguiendo de cerca este asunto para ver
si ha habido algún golpe técnicamente
los policías de la moral no tienen
herramientas para golpear son tienen
porras ni ninguna otra herramienta una
voz tu mirada en la base militar las
autoridades tienen una versión diferente
de los hechos respaldada dicen por esta
grabación que parece haber sido editada
más a mí me fue detenida por no cumplir
el estricto código de vestimenta iraní
la policía afirma que tuvo un problema
de salud mientras esperaba en una
comisaría de la moral con otros
detenidos dicen que tuvo un ataque al
corazón pero su familia niega que
sufriera de alguna enfermedad cardíaca
en las imágenes parece que se desploma
mientras habla con otras personas más
tarde murió en el hospital
de gran prometió una investigación
completa sin embargo su muerte ha vuelto
a poner en el punto de mira a la policía
de la moral iraní y sus estrictas leyes
que obligan a las mujeres a cubrirse el
pelo ya llevar ropa holgada en los
últimos meses activistas de derechos
humanos han instado a las mujeres a
quitarse el velo para desafiar el código
de vestimenta islámico de gran